[Music]
how should people think about mental
shortcuts or mental models and are there
any that come to mind that you think are
particularly valuable i'll tell you
about a few
and i'll tell you where to get more
perfect
let's take
a notion that economists call by their
priestly name
externalities
have you heard of that term i have i
have heard the term okay good most
people have not as it turns out so
you're
you're way ahead already
well i'll see where we go
an externality simplistically is
a consequence that's of somebody's
action
that's generally not intended
and it's usually bad
but it's sometimes good i'll give you
examples of each uh of varying sizes
here's a bad one that happened to me uh
actually last week
i go out to get my car and i find out
that the tires flap
i look
and i see a sheet metal screw
in the sidewall
which means that this tire is going to
have to be replaced
so i end up taking care of the problem
where did the problem come from
most likely i think
down the road from me there's been a lot
of construction going on
i've noticed as i go for walks
that
pieces of metal
are often lying in the road sheet metal
screws nails
other things that aren't good for tires
i pick them up when i happen to walk by
but i don't get them all
and the workers are curiously
depositing more not very many but it
only takes one to give me a flat
so
this is
an unintended
bad consequence of the work going on
there
who benefits
well the homeowner does because he
doesn't have to police his guys to clean
up carefully and sweep the streets
afterwards he doesn't have to spend
another
five dollars a day on sweeping labor to
make sure that none of these things are
there but it cost me five hundred
dollars for a new tires unfortunately
it's a tesla plaid with a 10.5 inch wide
michelin tire so the tires are not cheap
so
this is an unintended bad consequence
for me that saves a very small amount
for
the guy who's doing the construction a
few drawers down
let's take
a little bigger one
when i was a chemistry
student back at age 14 in 1946
teaching myself i mean there was wasn't
a decent chemistry class around
i came across a fellow named cevante
arenas
the great swedish physical chemist from
the latter part of
the 19th century
he at that time
and i learned it then
did a study of
how
gases in the atmosphere trap heat
and he explained how much the heat
trapping power was of various gases
including carbon dioxide he explained
very clearly how much carbon dioxide
would contribute to global warming as it
increased so this was known way back
then i knew it as a 14 year old and the
mechanism is obvious you can sit
behind a
plate glass window
when the sun is shining and feel
everything heat up around you the
greenhouse effect
so
it's it's simple it's obvious it's got
plenty of science behind it
what do people do now
well
they create a negative externality by
polluting people drive around in cars
and dump co2 into the atmosphere and
each individual is convenienced by being
able to drive around in his car
but he
contributes to a global problem a
problem that won't come back perhaps to
haunt him
if he doesn't live long enough or maybe
gradual so gradually doesn't notice it
but everybody together is busy
contributing this major externality
to the world
which leads to a second little mental
model it's called the tragedy of the
commons that's a pretty famous thing by
a guy named garrett harden
and the simple example is you've got a
village with a little green in the
middle and it's got a lot of grass
growing and only a few people live in
the village
so one guy has sheep and he lets his
sheep graze on the green and there's
plenty of grass so that's not a problem
a few more people move in they get some
sheep they turn them loose on the green
pretty soon they're too many sheep for
the green that's all eaten up
so
each person acts in his own
self-interest
but
collectively
what they do is against the common good
so that's another little
mental model or idea
so the whole collection of these
these things that are out there that are
very valuable
for thinking purposes
one collection is there's a 50
a 50 item collection that came out
under
inc period on the internet about from
elon musk it's quite good
there's also charlie munger's book poor
charlie's almanac yeah which has a lot
of these things embedded in it
one of my favorites is uh
it has a strange name
of uh fundamental attribution error and
i didn't like the name i said charlie
why are you calling this fundamental
attribution error well
charlie actually just picked it up from
sociology and psychology that's what
they call it and
i thought it's a terrible name you
should call it something else but as i
thought about it some more i just said
it's actually not a bad dame after all
roughly speaking
what it does
is
it's a human tendency
to
make assumptions
that are not
fully justified by the evidence for
instance you go to lunch
and
the person you invited doesn't show up
so you begin to
speculate well
maybe he just forgot he's a forgetful
guy or uh maybe
since we had a little quarrel two weeks
ago maybe that was it maybe he's just
mad and he's to show me or something of
that sort you start making enough stuff
to try to explain it
but you don't have the evidence for it
it turns out that he had a car actually
on the way and he's busy dealing with
all the fall off in a car accident
two hours later you find out what
actually happened and
it's too bad and he apologizes profusely
but you didn't have any idea what
actually happened you just started
making stuff up
that is something that humans do over
and over and we're wired for it it's
it's evolutionary
it ties into a famous book thinking fast
and slow daniel kahneman yes exactly
so he has an example there of you're in
the forest
and
you hear a roar
you don't stop to find out where the
roar is coming from you run up the
nearest tree because it might be a lion
in fact it might be something entirely
different but you don't take any chances
you react
and if it's not aligned you've made
fundamental attribution error you
attributed to being a lion when it
wasn't
but it saved your life
often when when it wasn't an attribution
error so
that ties in with something else which
is learning how to think
if you think fast it's kind of
emotionally from the gut
responding without really reflecting
you will make a lot of mistakes
sometimes though it's a way of saving
your life for example somebody else fire
you're you're at the door of the theater
you run out the door
immediately
before you find out whether there is a
fire
that might or may not have been but
running out the door before this time to
reflect in which case might be too late
is a good thing to do but i hold it up
for everybody else too as i run out
you